my name is Joelle and I'm a co-parent so
growing up I never heard the term
co-parent I heard a lot of other things
though I for starters absentee father
sperm donor that's a good one dead be
dead and my personal favorite baby daddy
baby daddy for those not in the know
refers to an individual who helps to
conceive a child but does little else
baby daddy is also someone who's not
married by law to the mother of said
child growing up I thought co-parent was
reserved primarily for white families
that started Netflix primetime dramas it
still kind of does but it wasn't used to
explain the role of a parent right
either you had kids or you didn't and no
one in my social circles are at our
dinner table was having complex
conversations about the role father's
played in that conversation right a a
more balanced open loving approach to
parenting was not something we were
discussing within our social circles a
majority of the time the father's I knew
of growing up were barely present or
just completely non-existent co-parent
wasn't a term I heard or saw where I
grew up where I came from I come from
the hood that hood would be Creston I
have a new 188th and the Bronx and for
one part this was up so appreciate that
for a lot of us in that hood there was
only one person we could already turn to
for food shelter warmth love discipline
our mothers my mother who I playfully
called Linda T was my first example of
real love and what showing up as a
healthy co-parents Ingle mother a woman
who would have benefited greatly from
having a secure and stable partner as a
co-parent so I vowed right whenever I
got married my boo and I will be
together forever
you know we we share the same bed in
home we sleep under the same covers we
argue at IKEA normal stuff my partner
would feel seen and loved and our
children will grow up in a two-parent
household however things rarely ever end
up how we plan them our daughter Lila
has never known a household with both of
her parents living together under one
roof
her mother and I were never married we
dated on and off for several months
before we found out she was pregnant
up until then my mother didn't even know
she existed I was ashamed I was
embarrassed and at times I was suicidal
I was asking myself what was I doing
where was that going wrong I never
wanted the stigma or a label of what
some identified as the stereotypical
black father right
so absence he confrontational combative
not present it took a lot of work time
energy and effort for us to finally
finally realize that maybe co-parenting
for us didn't need to mean a shared
household and wedding bells that maybe
just maybe the way we show that Bisco
parents lay not only in the layered
nuances of our partnership but the
capacity within our hearts to tend to a
human that we helped create together it
would involve love in a nurturing and
safe environment that would feed Lila
long after we both left this earth fast
forward four years and Lila is now in
pre-k she loves gummies and she says
things like my heart is filled with love
she's the most loving compassionate
empathetic human being I know and the
reason I get to tell you all of this is
because she's back in the Bronx with her
mother you see this is co-parenting and
in an ideal world my mother would have
had a co-parent - she would have had
support
someone to show up and give her a break
a time off in an ideal world every
parent is a co-parent in an ideal world
both parents share the weight of the
work appropriately Lila's mother and I
have a schedule
some days I leave work and pickle I love
from school some days I don't
Laila's mother gets to go rock climbing
or study for the LSAT and I get to stand
in a room full of bold dynamic and
powerful women and talk about bad stuff
it is work it is beautifully hard work
dismantling the systems that would have
us believe a woman's primary role is in
the kitchen tending to all things
domestic while the hapless dad some was
all over himself whenever he has to
spend a weekend alone with the kids it
is work that needs to happen right now
you see far too often what it seems like
is when both parents are working one
person is typically tasked with
organizing a household and keeping the
home running that person is typically a
woman or someone who identifies as such
far too often those who identify as
mothers and as women have to sacrifice
their dreams in order to appease the
standard they have to sacrifice their
dreams in order to ensure that
motherhood motherhood takes precedence
over all else and I'm not here to say
that it doesn't but what I am here to
say is as equal partners and Co parents
it is our duty to ensure that our
co-parenting partners don't have to put
their passions their pursuits and their
dreams to the backburner
just because we're too self-absorbed to
show up as allies
[Music]
co-parent who makes the space possible
for everybody as a co-parent the time
I've gone to share and spend with Lila's
time I appreciate the time that has
allowed me to be fully present from my
child all right removing the notion that
the emotional labor required to raise a
child as a woman's work as a co-parent
Lila and I have built snowmen we've
played with acorns we've wrapped at a
soundtrack Moana I know you have to
she sat with me while I've led workshops
at Columbia University when I talk about
the intersections of poetry hip-hop and
theater we get to talk about her
emotions and her feelings because we
have exclusive time together and that
time is planned time it's organized
around not just my schedule but her
mother's both of us as Co parents have
unique parenting styles and we may argue
at times but what we can always agree on
is how to raise a human our human eye
will never fully understand or
comprehend what it means to hold the
child in my body for 10 months I will
never be able to understand the trials
and tribulations of breastfeeding the
work that it takes the emotional
physical psychological and emotional
toll that carrying a human can have on
the female body
what co-parenting does is say we can
create balance a more balanced home and
work life for everyone involved
co-parenting says that while parents who
may involve sacrifices yes the weight of
that sacrifice is not solely resting on
one parent alone no matter your
relational dynamic no matter how you
identify as a human being he she they Z
co-parenting says we can create space
and equity better communication empathy
I hear you I see you how can I show up
for you in ways that benefits our family
my goal I want more fathers to embrace
co-parenting as a model for a better
tomorrow a better today for ourselves
for co-parenting partners for our
families for our community I want more
fathers talking about fatherhood openly
candidly honestly lovingly right I want
more people to recognize that black
fathers in particular are more than the
court system
more than child support amore what the
media might betray us to be our role as
fathers our role as parents our value as
parents is not dependent on the zeros at
the ends of our checks but the capacity
within our hearts to show it for our
families for the people we love for our
little ones being a father is not only a
responsibility it's an opportunity this
is for Dwayne this is for Kareem but Dre
in this is for bigs this is for bula
this is for tyronn this for all the
black fathers who were showing up on a
day to day basis this is for Charles
Lorenzo Daniels my father who didn't
have the language or the tools to show
up in the ways that he wanted to thank
you my name is Joel oh hi Bria hi West
che
[Applause]